will is in Nashville
I will how are you hey I'm good Dave
hurry sir better than I deserve what's
up good man I just got a quick question
about my son he goes to UT K and he's
not done very well with his grades I
guess over the last three years he's
still classified as a sophomore and we
had some money for him for school and
unfortunately he's out of that money now
and I do not want to co-sign a loan for
him he makes me feel super guilty about
it and I just want to know what my other
options are besides him not okay let me
get this straight
he's underperforming but you're supposed
to feel guilty well yeah well that's a
conversation that might go differently
on my deck well I'd like to hear what
you have to say yeah I mean I mean I
listen to you all the time I know what
you're going to say yeah I mean I love
this kid and I'm gonna knock him not on
his heads what I'm gonna do so here's
this here's the deal University of
Tennessee if you live in Tennessee is
not that expensive get a job get six of
them walk dogs yeah babysit babies mow
grass deliver stuff with your little car
and work because what he's doing right
now is drinking beer not going to class
because if you go to class you can
graduate right if you got me if you got
decent level of IQ you go to class you
can graduate now you might not get a
degree in chemistry I got a degree in
finance but all I did was go to class
and I graduated in four years and I
worked 40 to 60 hours a week while I was
in school
do you work when you were in school well
I did does junior Birdman work
not really no didn't think so Fred job
yeah so he's about to work summers here
summers here and I'm gonna let him feel
guilty while he's working like 80 hours
Oh
week right I mean I just don't know what
to do like about his living quarters it
gives it has to be paid for as well I
mean I'd win next fall right well well
yeah
is he home for this all right well no
he's living in an apartment because last
year he decided he won't live in one of
the group apartments Oh though and how's
he gonna pay for that
well he's been paying for we paid for it
until the winter semester started okay
well I guess if he wants to stay in the
apartment he's gonna get like seven jobs
I don't know that's what you would do
that's what I would do I think he can do
it he's just got to decide that it's up
to him and sit up to you you're not a
walking ATM and he's not been performing
in the classroom which makes this doubly
hard so I will roll up our sleeves at
home with our budget and I'll try to
pitch in some cash out of our budget and
help you get through this son but you
about to go to work Bubba that's that's
how the conversation would sound on my
deck
[Music]